what the is going on I like to party
Jesus honey wax this is unwaxed get in
lizard we're going shopping with Sophia
and cine Salone did we just become best
friends
[Music]
y hello everybody and welcome back to
another episode of the unwaxed podcast
with your favorite sister Sophia and
cinee I'm feeling like dooo so am I but
for different reasons Sophia you just
took too much Melatonin last night okay
I was still hung over from three or two
days ago what day is it today Sunday two
days ago I'm dying right now I know no
no no I feel like when I drink now I
feel it the week after the whole entire
time and then the thought of going out
again feels like it's torturous but the
fact that you went out after the night
you had is psychotic here's my issue on
Monday I like to make plans for the
weekend and sometimes I go oh I can do
Thursday and then a dinner with my
friends on Friday and then go out
Saturday it sounds fun yeah in theory in
theory right the execution of it is
horrendous I am down so bad but you know
what I was thinking about it this
morning and I even talked to my mom
about it because I always have to call
my mom the morning after I go out cu she
calms my anxiety down and I was like you
know what this is the reason we moved to
New York to have fun to go out more to
drink more to be more social
and let me tell you I did that and then
some I think you need to do that this
year because that's what I did last year
and I'm feeling the repercussions of it
now and now I'm in my old wom phase
where sop I think you're 27 she's like
I'm in my old woman I'm considered
officially late 20s so this is the time
where going on Zillow and Ikea and
Pinterest is my version of fun with a
glass of spearmint tea rather than going
out to a club taking sh
looking at hot guys that is like that
sounds like a blast but this is because
we are in different you're in your mid
20s that's true that's what I did but
then I crashed and burned after I made
it my resolution for 2024 to go out more
and think less because I think even the
idea of going out for me I have this
weird social anxiety where making the
plan texting the person going to meet
them say oh God is my Uber going to be
late what do I wear like that whole
process leading up to going out makes me
not want to go out but when I'm out it's
a great time and I have fun it's just
the mental hurdle and I think honestly
you have the the best way to get over
the I guess the anxiety pre anxiety
about going out like the thought of like
oh who am I going to rent into like how
am I going to look is actually making a
hype up playlist while you're getting
ready because I truly believe that
getting ready is the best part and when
you have such a good routine about like
okay I have my little cute headband with
the ears on I have all my favorite
makeup laid out I know my my vision of
how I want to do it and the music it
just makes like all right I'm ready to
go I agree because I always think this
is so stupid and the girls that get it
get it you know sometimes when you do
your makeup before going out and
everything is just working perfectly
you're like why is my wing amazing and I
applied my false lashes with no issues
and then my hair is doing what I want it
to do so you're like this is going to be
a good night the I had this happened to
me a couple of days ago where everything
was going wrong like I placed my lash in
the middle my skin the worst is when
your concealer and your foundation's
peeling Andel like what is it peeling
off and it's like curling up it looks
like skin it looks like your skin is
peeling off but it's not your skin and
then that honestly then your hair looks
like mine today and it just becomes just
the worse and then you just can't think
about like I don't want to go out I had
to put a hat on for several reasons one
being I have so much moose and dry
shampoo from this weekend should I just
go through what happened yeah you should
I mean it was a weekend guys it was epic
I was on Cloud9 so I'm still making
friends in the city so I'm trying to say
yes and go out and meet new people my
girlfriend goes we're going to do a
dinner our other friend just broke up
with his girlfriend he's down bad we got
a rally together the dangerous combo say
less because I'm also the type of person
where I will I won't peer pressure you
but I'll push you if you're in a bad
place to be in a better one through
alcohol sorry so I go to this restaurant
and it's eight people right and it's
just me and my one girlfriend and it's
all guys one that's a dangerous
combination so dangerous all the guys at
the table are saying oh we're all going
to do rounds of martinis I am not a
martini girl one because that's not a
cocktail to me there's no mixer there's
no uh way you can get kind of so nothing
dilutes it there's no there's no easy
into the drun you have one you're
smashed right so everyone's having a Jin
Martini a vodka martini I haven't had
vodka since the War of 1812 it's not for
me so I whispered to the bartender I
said can you make a martini with tequila
what but I did that's literally a
tequila shot it was tequila and like a
drop of Routh like that is what I and I
didn't have one I didn't have two Gnar I
had three I had three why because all
the guys were like we're doing another
one me think I can keep up with a grown
ass man's body is beyond me okay also
I'm eating lettuce cups it's already a
dangerous combination so I have three
Mar teis and then we go okay we're going
to go to our friend's birthday party
right I walk into the party I don't see
one person I know what did I do I turned
around by myself left after 10 seconds
of walking inside why because I saw a
dive bar across the street it was
calling my name I take two shots didn't
need to didn't need to I go back to the
party they're going let's go to a club I
said say less I go to the club no one
was really drinking at the table I
thought let's keep the buzz going I'm
feeling warm and fuzzy inside I'm taking
poles from the bottle warm and fuzzy is
just the alcohol heating you up it's
heating me up and I don't know why we
were doing PS polls alone it wasn't like
you know how sometimes when you're in a
club people are like let's do round of
shots and everyone's doing
no one was doing that I think I think
the moment where you start taking poles
from a bottle at a club is the moment
you should consider in the morning going
home that is the moment you go oh I've
really went far beyond what I needed to
be doing you know when you're at that
level of drunk where everything is just
euphoric and you're I was in such a
silly goofy mood I was so happy in that
moment that I just wanted to keep that
feeling going I sound like an alcoholic
this is not good but I wanted to keep a
going so I thought I have to keep
drinking to keep it going and I should
have learned my lesson my dad always
tells me nothing good happens after
midnight well is it two or midnight
Midnight definitely nothing good happens
after I push it to two in you're in New
York nothing good happens after two if
you're going to a club at 2 a.m. which
is what sustem was basically doing it's
downhill so I was I was so obviously bad
but I wasn't falling I just um you know
my eyes started blinking one at a time
like everything was going a little
cross-eyed a lovely gentleman says let
me get you an Uber home I said God bless
you thank you so much I get in the Uber
I go home I fell so hard I'm surprised
it didn't wake you up also this was at
6:30 in the morning I forgot to mention
can we just pause you're surprised
didn't wake me up she comes in barreling
I think at 3:30 in the
morning
Sophia so open my door I'm groggy I was
in the middle of my sleep and she goes
are you
awake I wanted to hang out I wanted to
tell you about my night I know I was
like it's 3:00 in the morning that's
what you signed up for when you live
with me in my new era so listen now it's
6:30 in the morning don't know why I
stayed up for another 3 hours I'm in my
bathroom also you know it was a good
night when you look at your legs and
you're like where did all these bruises
come
from okay this is this is what I knew
I'm not doing well I'm in my bathroom
and I'm holding on to the counter so I
can just hold on with one hand and brush
my teeth with the other hand 6:30 in the
morning you
guys and for some reason I just start
swaying like like music was playing in
my head and I was just swaying minding
my business yeah all of a sudden I start
to like slow motion you know those
fainting goats when like every limb goes
stiff and then they just sort of slowly
topple to the side kind of I slow motion
even though I'm holding on to the C that
wasn't enough stability for me fall into
my shower take everything off the table
knock my shelf off with me and now I'm S
I hit my head so hard and I it was like
one of dangerous that is no I know but
it was like one of those movie scenes
where you get caught in the shower
curtain and just sitting in the shower
and I sat there I was like ow and I sat
there for about 10 minutes cuz I was
just so comfortable I was so
comfortable no when you're drunk like
any floor any surface you're like oh I
just want to here I will there's
actually nothing more dangerous than
falling in the shower and I the fact
that you thought that was a comfortable
position is it just proves to me what
level of intoxication you were because I
fell in the shower a couple months ago
and I had a moment where I pause and I
go why isn't the water turning red okay
nothing's open no I literally thought I
got my head open no I that's that's what
I'm saying that I was shaking when I got
up cuz I was I had such an adrenaline
freak out you just leisurely hung out
out in the bathtub yeah no it was it
wasn't my finest moment but it was one
of those nights where regardless of how
ill I felt the next day I'm so happy
that I did that I am too it was so
needed I called my mom she was like you
needed that for your soul you needed to
have fun you needed to get drunk you
needed to go out you needed to break
some hearts get some who cares if a year
of your life is just taken off from how
much alcohol you had it's good for the
soul it really does but the next morning
oh you guys we're moving we have to look
at apartments right hold on you're
forgetting a very important detail
because she just said we're
moving sopia comes into my room the
other
day eyes all welted up from crying okay
not that trtic she so her face is
flushed she's a little pale she's
shaking she is shaking I'm not shaking
you're ridiculous into my room sits on
the edge of my bed and I know you're
about to say something
dramatic and before you even said
anything you go I need to talk to you
and I said I [__] knew it I knew
exactly what you were going to say
before you said it okay I'll just tell
you exactly what I said without all the
dramatics it was dramtic with it no I
just said to her I had a thought I
actually couldn't sleep this night when
I came up to her and it was probably a
couple days ago and I realized that one
we're not going to have this moment of
living together that much sooner because
look I'm not saying I'm I'm meeting my
husband tomorrow or she is but I'm
saying that there is going to be a time
where we're not going to live with each
other for the next 50 years you know and
we're only in New York for you know a
short period of time CU I don't think
either of us want to raise children here
and so I kind of like I could not stop
thinking about that and I hate where we
were living like I truly don't like our
apartment so I want to move but I said I
wanted to move with her so h i felt
extremely validated so much to the point
where I brought up this moment to my
therapist she did tell me was so happy
because I get why you wanted to move out
on your own and you felt like sometimes
I understand like living with your
younger sister you feel it stunts your
growth and you want to take another
chapter in your life so I get the whole
reason why you wanted to and I also
think that places when there's a lot
that's happened in that place doesn't
feel good memories I kind of needed like
a refresh and for me though no
definitely not I mean we've had we've
had our tiffs here and there but you
know I think that we're both in this
really really good mindset coming into
this year and I'm like it would be nice
to go into this good mindset with a
really good apartment I felt so
validated you guys because I truly I
even told my mom a few days prior cuz I
was looking at apartments alone I said
Mom I really don't want to move out like
I don't want to leave sopia I don't want
to be alone I I just want to have this
time with her so I don't understand why
she wants to be alone or apart from me
and I know you didn't mean it this way
but in my dulu brain I felt like
rejected right I felt so rejected and I
had a I'll be very Frank maybe because
there's still some alcohol in me I had a
very tough year last year like very
tough and I'll admit I wasn't the most
Pleasant Peach to be around I was a bit
I was like a prickly pear I wasn't
exactly positive all the time I was just
in a dark place hence therapy I'm in a
much better place now but I felt for
that period of time you know sometimes
when you're just in a bad mindset it
doesn't matter who's around you how
happy they are sometimes you just can't
be like you just can't pull yourself out
of that negative place and that's where
I was like no matter how nice you were
how great our family was how great my
life is in that moment moment like you
just can't seem to pull yourself out of
it because it's it's not the external
things that are controlling it it's what
you're feeling internally exactly and
the worst part about all of that is you
sometimes feel like you can't even
control what comes out of your mouth or
your emotions it's like being on your
period like sometimes you're just a
raging monster and you can't help what
comes out next true so I knew and it
hurt me that I was even doing this to
you guys I knew that I was not great to
be around and I hated that and I I knew
you guys felt that and you didn't even
want to be around me and and Mom and
Scarlet they're like Jesus like let's
avoid suine which I don't blame you and
the worst part about that is like I knew
that I was behaving this way but I just
couldn't help it so you were just a
piece of the reason why it was like
you're like 1/8 of the reason so I don't
want you to think that because it look
it it was a factor in it and it
definitely made me feel more encouraged
to go to have this time by myself but
then a lot of other things were the
cause of why I wanted to alone no of
course of course but that brings me back
to why I felt so validated and why I
brought this up to my therapist because
I said I feel like for the first time in
a long time I'm not so miserable to be
around and people still want to be
around me and I was just so happy that
you still wanted to be around me cuz
like you're my best friend and I love
you so much and I'm glad that you're
seeing a change yeah so much to the
point where you're like I could actually
do another year with this [__] true so
I felt so happy okay that's good a happy
it made you feel happy because I want
that's the thing is I did see a change
and I also you know it's sisters go
through so I will actually you know what
I've talked to so many people that have
sisters and siblings and when I tell
them I live with my sister they are
actually very impressed and this is like
um this is not because of you or me
whatever but a lot of people can't live
with their sister a lot of people
actually most people I've heard like
they're best friends with their sister
but there's a difference between 247
with your sister who you can be the most
upfront and honest with it's like with
siblings like you're never going to you
know repress yourself for how you're
actually feeling about a situation so a
lot of people don't end up doing that
and because it causes more fights and
the fact that we're able to and work
together is like pretty impressive and
honestly like yes we get into bickers
we're sisters and we are very loud so of
course like we bickered on the way here
way we on the way here and then I said
what should I cook us for dinner like
that's just how yeah that's just how it
works and so yeah I know I'm excited
because I feel like so back to what we
were saying about the apartment hunting
we were apartment hunting and we found a
really good place yes but I I was still
drunk but she was still intoxicated the
next day cinee found a random Bodega it
was sweet talking the bodega man he gave
us some fresh juices I said I need you
to make me lemon juice Ginger carrots
and beets I want to expel every drop of
alcohol in my system right now but this
is the problem every typ every time we'd
go to a listing she would tell the real
sorry I'm just so puffy and hung over
and at every single one by the last one
because we were re we were reing another
apartment that we really liked I said
sinee we want this one don't tell the
guy you're hung over he has a child and
a wife he wants to hear that his tenants
are going to be no she didn't like drunk
as a SC I was like look we're going to
be drunk and like do our thing cuz we're
young in our 20s and New York but I'm
like for this one play it cool play we
actually I'd like to give myself a pat
on the back the first one we saw was the
one we're going to get yes we're signing
the lease today Y and I found it I and
this is this is the crazy part we have
looked probably at what 15 different
apartments it is really hard right now
to find a place in New York it's crazy I
don't know I don't know if it's because
people understand that moving during the
winter is not the the time to usually
move it's kind of like the time you
avoid it because the weather sucks but
of course of course like this is also
the best time to find a place but right
now it's horrible and we went into so
many and what we kind of gathered by the
end of it was there are such distinct
energies in every single apartment you
go to and you can feel the one that's
right for you immediately like the one
that we like and we walked into just it
felt like a home yeah you know what I'm
saying like maybe because there was a
newborn in there well yeah the guy had
just had a newborn and he's married and
they're like moving up town and so they
decorated in a very home style
it made us feel happy like oh okay
perfect we have our little kit our
living room we see trees it's like it
doesn't show any City type it looks like
we're in Boston a little bit it's very
cool it's so cool very chic yeah it
actually is I'm so excited I excited and
it is smaller than the one we have now
which is kind ofun no it's great though
I love it better actually cuz it gets
you know we're closer but guess you want
to be closer but guess what I get an
office in a library I'm making a I'm
putting one of the smallest rooms I'm
getting it and making it a library soy
made hers a Glam room but I'm making
mine a little reading literally our
personalities to a te Sophia is making
the third bedroom an office and I made
mine a vanity with a Glam room yeah I
make well because what if we need to
have zoom calls yeah but what if we want
to look good I got to beat my face also
did you get your eyebrows done um like
three weeks ago three weeks ago like
three and a half two and a half weeks
ago there's no way they look like that
good three weeks grown out
I swear on my life two and a half weeks
ago let me ask you this do you think I'm
wearing too much makeup right now you're
wearing a lot more than I am but you
always answer my question though do you
think I'm wearing too much makeup right
now cuz I am I put a lot on oh really I
no I didn't think so I thought you were
wearing I feel like well I don't have my
eyes done but you have your skin and
your eyes done so I thought you put a
lot more a lot do I look like I have a
little makeup B you don't need a lot of
makeup though I do what are you talking
about no you don't well lately I've been
better I look like a little boy if I
don't that's so not true you're laughing
cuz you know it's true no cuz you just
called yourself a little boy I mean you
are wearing a Ford hat and you know go
on no I won't keep going you know what
some of the men that listen to the show
really do humble me sometimes about my
appearance really the most recent
comment that really stuck with me um and
oh my God I can't believe I'm saying
this last episode I actually thought
about this comment and this man and did
something that was just so heinous
um he was saying like how dare Sophia
let cinee film an episode with like her
fake tan only on her face and not on her
chest and hands and then I watched the
episode back my hands are transparent
but my face is like super pink from all
the foundation I'm wearing and so the
last episode I put foundation on my
hands Tanner sinee that's how I feel
about the episode I was on another um we
were on another podcast a couple of
weeks ago and someone commented in the
comments um Can someone blend her
bronzer and you do a little blotchy I
did a blotch do I do I have it now is it
blotchy turn your face no that's how
it's good no no no it's good your skin
looks good let's talk about that oh yeah
so we actually did want to go into this
really quick and I won't make this a
super long thing but I have been talking
about a lot and I feel like skin topics
are so popular today because so many
people deal with bad skin and I've never
dealt with bad skin before and I was
really lucky growing up to have those
little blemishes here and there but I
truly experienc what girls experience
with cystic acne and scarring and things
like that these last few months and I
will tell you I understand you when
you're crying in your car like you don't
want to leave your house you feel so
insecure it is truly like the hardest
thing to there's actually nothing that
makes your confidence plummet more than
having bad skin it's like you can't even
cover it with makeup cuz you still see
the texture and everything but as you
can see I've cleared it and I will say
this this all came up in October and
everyone was telling me you should get
on spiractin you need to get on um
what's it called uh um what's the acne
medication that everyone Accutane all
this stuff because it was not stopping I
was really determined to do my research
and figure out holistic ways and healthy
ways to get it out without having to
take any medicine and I figured it out
because look at my skin it's gone knock
crazy it's so crazy and no one believed
me and it was like Rumble still skin
before it was bad thanks sisa like a
toad okay but I can say now because your
skin is perfect it is better it is
better I'm just dealing with acne scars
but I will tell you if you're dealing
with acne or if you're you know what
also when you start to hit your late 20s
your hormones change and that's what
happened to me and my hormones are super
imbalance my cortisol levels were super
high so I will tell you the three things
that I totally changed that made my skin
I still do it today so it's been like a
three-month process that's cleared my
skin and stayed clear okay so for my
morning routine this is all about my
diet so I've reduced the amount of milk
sugar and alcohol totally like totally
reduce every single thing in the morning
specifically this is sounds crazy but
like if you stick to this this actually
does help you have celery juice in the
morning and a tumeric shot celery juice
cleanses out your body and tumor is an
inflamm an anti-inflamatory tummy not
hurt it does I got used to it my stomach
and my body love it now it's like you
don't poop your pant no I definitely
want it definitely it clear it does help
clear you out so if you also are someone
that deals with you know being a little
backed up celery juice on an empty
stomach seriously can get it all out a
lot of tequila you can't tell te because
you can't tell me the next morning you
don't feel snatched you do feel snatched
you actually you're you're more I'm less
prone to that stuff yeah this is a
personality difference going there we go
so celery juice and turmeric
anti-inflamatory I have two Brazil nuts
because it bring I don't know what
Brazil nuts do but Brazil nuts I forgot
the name for it but it brings down a
certain level so it like balances out
your hormones wondering why you're
eating like a nut every night yeah I
always eat these two Brazil nuts and
then at night I
have can I just say this without
you you liter have made a comment every
single thing I'm still
drunk um at night I have spearmint tea
and licorice tea like you put that
together can you I'm not I didn't say
anything you've literally made a gag
noise at every single thing I've said so
far I'm keeping my mouth shut my skin
care as well in the morning I do double
cleanse always double cleanse to get
your makeup off and really stick to a
super super simple routine in the
morning I focus on vitamin C's to
brighten my skin and also a lot of
hydration and then at night I focus on
retinol retinol will really kill
everything off and if you're consistent
your face is going to peel I do 1% which
is pretty aggressive but once the
peeling stops then you really start to
see results and that's what kind of took
away the major ones that's helped
drinking a lot of water and then the
most important one is my mental health
because I think that last year I went
through a lot of anxiety I said this on
the solo episode and I've said it on
other episodes just like suine like went
through stuff I went through stuff as
well and I think that once you kind of
confront like oh I'm really stressed
about X Y and Z it's so important to
tackle those on and then also know
what's going to make you calm in the
morning so I've been doing meditations
in the morning like I know that we
always go like Sophia are so different
but I think it's really important to
like calm your brain at night in the
morning like do things like don't look
at your phone before bed I go on long
walks I don't do like high impact
workouts I don't involve myself or put
myself in environments like clubs too
much or like too many bad people or I've
just kind of like limited my circle and
it's totally helped my anxiety so that's
really what helped me I was going to
make a video on Tik Tok so maybe later
you guys can see like a little bit more
down I think what you did that is much
better cuz I would have taken the
shortcut and just done mutane just to
kill it you were so consistent and what
was it like a 3mon journey it was like
yeah 3 and a half months that's a long
time to keep something up it was hard it
was and it was embarrassing like I at
our Halloween party I had like major
acne everywhere and I was looking at
those photos that we loved but I had so
much all over my cheeks and chin and it
was just like it was so weird to see cuz
that was something I haven't had before
and I was thinking okay I'm I I just
don't like medicine and I think that you
can really heal your body holistically
and you can you know find some ways that
work for you and then there there are
some cases where you have to take
medicine and don't not do that but those
are the things that help clear my skin
and I'm going to continue to do it just
because regardless if my acne is gone I
think it's like I want to make it even
better and better so yeah you're going
to have the healthiest kids ever I am
well I'm just I'm going to be that Mom
that has a lot of tricks and hacks for
their children like okay like when you
have a migraine put your feet in boiling
hot water stop yeah that does help if
you want to get tan eat a lot of carrots
or I heard if you're car sick sniff a
lemon yeah see things like that and
you're going to come over to antin's
house and I'm like here's the sugar
cereal don't tell your mother I'm going
to have sugar cereal I have to you know
SC doesn't have a sweet tooth like me at
night I have to have something sweet at
night speaking of which we need to order
more ice cream that I know we actually
we ate it all you know we're getting so
we're getting so gross no the other
night I ate it all I was this is how
gross we're getting cuz sometimes when
we really want something sweet we're
like oh shoot there's nothing in our
pantry so we start making like the most
disgusting combinations I was putting um
like peanut butter cereal in the ice
cream which actually doesn't sound that
wa it was peanut butter cereal and
peanut butter ice cream then I was also
putting like a Saltine in my mouth yeah
that was also kind of gross a Saltine
with peanut butter ice cream and peanut
butter doesn't sound bad with Saltines
but Sophia we literally had sandwiches
the other day and you're shoving
barbecue chips in there you can't sit
here and tell me my conc are gross she
thinks that putting chips in your
sandwich is really gross like that for
me is the equivalent of putting fries in
my burger in a milkshake should we get a
burger tonight yes when you said you
were wanting to cook I was like okay yes
yeah she was saying she wanted to cook
and we would have made like some salmon
which I love salmon but what do you want
I want a burger I want some meat I need
some meat on me yeah you do yeah I do
you want some meat um you know what what
meat you didn't get sorry
33-year-old that was the grossest
transition I'm so proud of you you about
proud of you talked about I'm proud of
you I'm proud of you I'm proud of you
it's a w I'm proud of you thank you this
is okay here's the issue you guys here's
the issue here's the issue one guy here
yeah I'm also going to blame Chris for
this because you encouraged me no this
is a you'll see encour I'll tell you
I'll tell you right now I'll tell you
right now you encouraged me because I
asked I was like don't you think this is
cool and you're like yeah I love when
women do that so I did it I did it oh
like you went and hit on somebody no
when remember last episode I was saying
oh my new thing is asking people out
uhhuh yeah no I got stood up I got stood
up you guys all right I'm actually so
sorry all I do on this podcast is hype
you guys up then give you false
information um by the way your Tik Tok
of you talking about we have we clipped
the part where sine says ask guys out it
got such like many very reviews like
because everyone said don't do it don't
do it everyone which is so not what I
thought I thought everyone would be on
board with women ask guys out but
everyone was like no hold in your
feminine energy which is what I was
encouraging and actually now I
understand what they meant by that so
let me give you some background I asked
this guy out who by the way was pursuing
me for months every time he even saw me
in public and I didn't even recognize
him or say hello to him he would say oh
were you just at this place oh it was
good seeing you didn't yeah so he was
trying okay he was trying he was the
Pisces boy he like so I slid back in
months later and I asked him out we had
plans for Thursday at 8:00 p.m. well
also that was what thing he did good at
was when cinee did ask him out he said
Thursday 8:00 yeah well don't get too
excited guys cuz guess what Thursday
rolled around 100 p.m. 2: p.m. 3 p.m. 4
p.m. I go that's funny haven't heard
anything from this guy in a few days is
there even still a date nearly
5:00
strikes and he gives me some some
[__] excuse that he has a client
dinner and blah blah blah which first of
all you know about your client dinner
okay so why did you wait till three
hours before the day to cancel on me and
then the worst part is he was just like
oh yeah here's the good news though I'm
free next week I said how is that good
for me like either make a new plan or
buy and this is the thing guys if you
ask a girl and you're doing at last
minute you have to cancel the only way
you should be responding to canceling a
date last minute is next week are you
free Tuesday or Thursday around 8:00 I
have a really good place that I want to
take you to and I'm going to make it up
to you that's how you do it not good
news and bad news bad news I have to go
to a work dinner last minute good news
is I'm around until the like next
weekend it's just like okay what am I
supposed to do cheer like I'm wait
around so I I called in the recruits I
said how do I respond to this mom and
dad cuz Mom gives me the feminine touch
to it and Sly gives me the real hard
truth of how to handle someone like this
this man is 33 years old what made me
realize is older does not make you wiser
I think sometimes we think oh if you're
like dating 35 36 that they're going to
be so mature no no no no no no no no no
no no so I said what do I do you guys
parents helped me out they said don't
answer mhm what did I do I didn't answer
that got his attention he started double
texting and now I said I freaking got
him hook line and sinker I got him right
where I want him I still don't really
know how I want to play this well but
actually actually he triple texted he
triple texted and this just goes back to
what Sly always gives the best advice he
always said if you want to get someone's
attention and you don't know what to say
to them on text say nothing cuz nothing
translates to that person better than
any text that you could be Conjuring up
and try to get their attention try to be
a little bitter nothing reads so much
louder and so I've realized I'm like
hold on here's the secret and it sucks
and obviously you want to call it
playing games I call it playing smart
and protecting your heart that bars that
was pretty good that was pretty good
that was so good okay s relax it was
fine okay she has good skin so she's
here like you think you're better than
me no okay but wait no no let me let me
you have more yeah I have more sorry I'm
on a roll okay so I was thinking about
it how to get someone to chase you okay
do nothing do nothing yeah and I wrote
this out and I don't want to mess it up
so I'm going to okay go ahead these are
my thoughts if you want them to text you
the more you show disinterest and
distance yourself that is when you're
going to actually see how much they are
interested in you if they don't see that
and they don't see that oh she's pulling
away she is not as responsive and she's
not chasing me and I'm expecting a text
but I didn't get one if he responds to
that with trying to make up for it or
trying to see you again then amazing you
know exactly where his head is at if he
doesn't answer if he doesn't notice if
he doesn't care he just showed you his
cards yeah he showed you exactly how he
feels about you this is also another
thing because this is only if you know
he has done something that has made you
think about how am I supposed to respond
this is not just a game like in the
beginning where it's you know it's not
necessary to ignore someone but I truly
believe that if a guy is giving you 50%
if you are encouraging that by
responding and then also adapting
yourself to his timeline and his
schedule then you are feeding into that
50% and then that guy is going to go
down to 30% and he's going to see how
far he can push it 100% And so you're
encouraging someone in the beginning of
your guys's relationship to give you 30%
because you're going to give 100 and
when he gives you 20 you have to give
110 and that's where the dynamic issue
is because you're giving all of your
energy to someone and he's only giving
20 because you have established that as
the Baseline for your relationship EXA
how you start a relationship with
someone and we're not even saying dating
like this is just first couple days of
really getting to know each other that
is going to play out how the
relationship is going to end up like if
I responded back to this guy oh yeah no
worries blah blah blah well I'm free on
tu Tuesday then he knows right there you
just gave away your cards he's going to
probably say oh I can get away with
anything like she she's cool with kind
of minimal effort and behavior totally
so you kind of really have to stick to
your guns and also
like yeah I I don't know a guy that a
guy that is that kind of like arrogant
and cocky just like you know that that's
what you're going to get in the
relationship don't ignore that flag
there was something I watched um uh yes
the other day and girl I forgot who the
girl was but she was talking about
people coming in and out of your life
and it actually seriously helped me kind
of I guess place in a box exactly why my
relationships ended up the way they did
and she she's religious so she kind of
put in terms of God but so I'll say the
version she said but I kind of do it
more as like just life in general she
said that God puts people in your lives
that are meant for you and takes them
away when they've done their purpose so
he has put deep well cuz think about it
like someone will come into your life
for a reason they will be there either
for the long run because they are meant
for you or maybe they're there to teach
you a lesson and they also leave and
that's also meant to be as is too like
people are not going to come into your
life and just stay in your life they are
going to leave eventually if it's
supposed to be that way so for me I kind
of saw this as okay like you can think
about an ex and you can like I have a
really hard time in C like knows this
about me I really dwell on the past like
I always am someone that re reignites
like old memories and things and like
what ifs 24/7 and this kind of put it
into a very simple way of thinking you
know that person was in my life for a
reason they came they did what they had
to do I am happy I'm sad I learned my
things with them and they also were
removed for the same reason is that
they're not meant for me in the future
because of where I am at so it kind of
made it go okay like I don't have to
really you know overthink or worry
because this is just how it was like
supposed to be 100% I always think um
you know how we say when someone like an
ex or someone sort of comes back into
your life MH like saying oh they always
come back that's not a flex no no think
about it they're coming back because
they want to see if you're stupid enough
to take them back or respond like
they're like oh she will like that's not
no doors need to be closed cuz we were
talking about this the other night why
is it whenever you feel like almost
discouraged with your dating life and
you're like oh [__] like nothing is
working and I'm trying and I'm trying
and I'm not getting anything to stick
why do you always sort of think about
your ex and you start to reminisce
actually I did something so bad I did
something so bad I have this role of
film that I've had for about two years
that I didn't develop because I know on
this role of film there's a [__] ton of
photos of me with my ex and Sophia with
her ex and I was like I can't I can't
see it I don't want to see it I
developed it the other day I thought I
was ready I was like you know you know
what I'm grown I've matured I've moved
on the photos were real cute yeah real
cute and I was like oh my God I miss
being in love I miss a relationship you
but that's what except by the way that's
what it was but it wasn't good it wasn't
good it was okay it had good moments no
but I'm saying you don't miss the
relationship you miss the love in the
relationship like that's what you're
honing in on it's not it's not you're
nostalgic about that person at all
because that person's out of your life
for reason you're nostalgic about like
the feeling of being in love and that's
just what happens and godamn dating is
tough but but I'm gonna be honest I'm
gonna be honest right now I wasn't going
to be honest but I'm going to be honest
because I feel like this podcast um we
just talked to each other and Chris and
so sometimes I treat it like no one's
out there listening or judging but here
we go did I send the photos to him
yes that was pretty gnarly sopia
slightly encouraged me because you were
like we're having a boring day let's
stir the pot a little bit no okay I mean
not in so many words no but I know
everyone says that you cannot be friends
with an ex which I totally agree but I
do think that there can be like a civil
Middle Ground talking basis no I
encouraged it because you guys are at a
great level like I would have never if
you guys were on like then I would have
said no also I thought the photos were
really cute so I was like I think if I
were him I'd want him to send me the
photos they're nice so I did and it was
very well received it was very wholesome
conversation we spoke off and on for a
day and then I said Sayan I talk you
again in another year and a half but it
was lovely yeah you're jealous cuz you
don't have that sorry I just I hate
having I like amicable endings with
everybody I just I'm just
such contr sometimes when you end a
relationship you're going to be the bad
guy and you sitting with that idea of
being the bad guy eats at you alive
because someone doesn't like you because
I I love like I hate hurting people but
you had you were hurting yourself by
staying in it I know I feel like people
can relate to that it's like when you
have to choose yourself for a second
then if you want to talk about relating
I just had a texted my ex yeah that's
true that's true it's don't do it do you
want to oh actually I wanted to talk
speaking of dating I listened I actually
it was on giggly Squad who also films
here which is kind of cool we love
gigglers I love them and I'm a giggler
and they they actually said something on
their podcast I really like about the 0
to 100 100 to zero thing what is it
where when men and women go into dates
the way they you know visualize or think
about the person across from them so
women go into dating with 100 to zero so
they go in with like high expectations
thinking about love like kind of
sometimes you go like all the what if's
like oh are we going to click like could
we be in a relationship and then slowly
as you guys date time and time again
like he has the Navy sheets oh he's like
doesn't answer that fast and so your
number goes down when as guys they start
at zero when they go into a relationship
and they don't really have that many
expectations but then as they start to
hang out with you more the number kind
of increases and so that's why do you
see what I'm saying the balance yeah
which is so true because you think about
you go into a date with like high
expectations you're ready to go wideeye
and the guys don't really but then as
they start to get to know you their
number starts to go up for them I wonder
what you could do that would subtract do
you think he's like oh she just gave me
the I she's back down to a 45 that's
like that's too that's too scoreboard
that would be really funny though he's
like oh she you start asking what's my
number oh she only likes cats -10
someone actually did give me [__] about
that the other day I think there's just
such a a cat person's also kind of a
Caren person yeah
H that is the rudest thing you've said
to me I that was that was fighting words
those fighting words yeah she's my
screen saver so what did you see the
animal that I uh want to get for us yeah
it looks a little in no that's not loves
doon's I love stop loves dachon I love
golden retrievers I just saw um it looks
mutated what are you talking about you
cannot cross a golden retriever golden
do and a doxen it was so cute they're
little wenas and they look like oh
they're little wi little dogs they look
like
ofas do you know how cute that is you
realiz how cute that is a little wiener
so little golden retriever wiener there
you go yes yes my God I so bad golden
weer we love them stop saying it like
that it's so gross I'm still drunk no
you're not you are sober and I'm on
melatonin right now okay wait to wrap
this episode up really quick oh no I
thought you
forget cuz there's something to my left
that I've been staring at the entire
episode Sophia lost a bet and we're
going to do this on the next episode
Sophia lost a bet we actually beted on
oh we're not doing it this episode no
we'll save it no we'll save it Sophie
lost a bet okay and if I
won I said you have to bring your
journal in and read an old entry and I
cannot wait to dive into this the next
episode I'm so sorry but I love you guys
done this before I know but it's going
to be so good it's going to be so good
thank you guys so much for tuning in to
this week's episode of the unwax podcast
please go on to YouTube Spotify Apple
podcast give us at five stars we are
shooting every single Tuesday and we'll
answer your questions if you only give
us with five stars and we love you guys
we love you bye bye